new york versinkt in der gewalt das
berichten unsere reporter von dort seit
monaten jeden tag neue brutale
gewalttaten in der stadt schauen sie mal
nur auf diese polizei
nachrichtenmeldungen der letzten stunden
in der bronx ta haben randalierer
glasflaschen auf diese polizisten
geworfen die polizisten werden brutal
attackiert sehen sie was da auf der
straße los war als die polizisten einen
mann wegen unerlaubten waffenbesitzes
dort festnehmen wollten gewalt gegen die
dann die in new york für ordnung sorgen
wollen und auch das ist wenig später
passiert in queens im östlichen teil new
yorks es ist da ein teenie der vor dem
wohnhaus erschossen worden ist er 14
jahre alt erst in einer garagenzufahrt
getötet und zudem polizeimeldungen der
letzten stunden gehört auch das aus
manhattan im schicken soho ein martial
arts kämpfer der hatte einen obdachlosen
zu boden gerissen der zuvor von
passanten brutal attackiert der zuvor
passanten brutal attackiert hatte ja das
ist die alltägliche gewalt in new york
und nur ein kleiner einblick in das was
in dieser metropole so in den letzten
stunden bei der polizei gemeldet wurde
wir sprechen mit unserem new york
korrespondent herbert bauernebel grüße
dich herzlich herbert warum das
berichtet du ja seit monaten
mittlerweile immer mehr brutale gewalt
in deiner stadt
es gibt verschiedene faktoren die
einfach hier latent für diese
gewaltwelle sorgen die eine gewaltwelle
die einfach nicht abebben mag es ist
einerseits natürlich den nachwirkungen
der korona virus pandemie hier in new
york und natürlich auch der den unruhen
die es gab nach dem tod von george floyd
all das hat zu einem dramatischen
anstieg bei der gewalt geführt besonders
auch bei schuss vorfällen in diesem
bereich ist es in den letzten wochen ein
wenig nach unten gegangen es gab mehr
verhaftungen von menschen mit waffen das
ist ein erster kleiner erfolg aber
insgesamt ist nach wie vor die
verbrechensrate um 31% höher als selbst
im gewalttätigen vorjahr um das ist
natürlich ein wirkliches
schreckenszenario besonders in einem
kritischen moment für new york city denn
die stadt ist nach wie gesagt zwei
jahren pandemie um george wright unruhen
bietet den ersten sommer halbwegs normal
und leidet nach wie vor unter dieser
hohen kriminalität die nachricht uhr
menschen abschreckt zurückzukommen ins
büro hier in new york und auch einige
touristen natürlich abschnitt welche
rolle spielen drogen
die drogenkriminalität ist relativ
stabil geblieben dass eines der größten
probleme scheint zu sein dass ist der
liberale strafvollzug hier in new york
es hat die reformen gegeben die bedeuten
dass menschen wenn sie behauptet werden
eigentlich garantiert eine kaution
hinterlegen können sie werden dem
richter vorgeführt und dann wie bei
einer drehtür eigentlich können sie
wieder hinaus und viele beginnen weitere
straftaten es ist jetzt gerade einmal
hier berühmt geworden in new york mit
101 belastungen wegen ladendiebstahl
hauptsächlich jedes mal wieder
freigelassen worden jedes mal wieder ein
verbrechen begangen und das frustriert
natürlich den neuen bürgermeister eric
adams der hierauf haben möchte aber auch
natürlich die polizei die hier immer
wieder gegen teilweise die gleichen
leute vorgehen muss new york herbert es
ist deine stadt seit so vielen jahren
gibt es gegenden die für dich absolut no
go ist also wo auch herbert bauernebel
unser usa-korrespondent sagte da kann
ich da will ich auf keinen fall hingehen
rio in new york
man muss es nicht so ganz dramatisch
sehen und es gibt gegenden die man gerne
meinen möchte natürlich dass hier ein
wenig mulmig unheimlich geworden ist ist
die zufälligkeit dieser gewalttaten und
es kann einem hier new york wirklich
überall treffen in der u-bahn am
gehsteig es sind sehr viele menschen
hier unterwegs die offensichtlich
geistige erkrankungen haben die
unberechenbar sind sehr viele obdachlose
es ist schon ein bisschen ein gefühl wo
man sich über die schulter schauen und
dass dieses gefühl hatte ich eigentlich
vor zwei drei vier jahren hier nicht in
new york sagt herbert bauernebel unser
new york korrespondent danke für deine
einschätzung new york eine stadt die
immer mehr in der kriminalität versinkt
[Musik]